la nascita di un bambino è il miracolo
della vita se ci pensate
scientificamente con un'eiaculazione
maschile si raggiungono circa mezzo
miliardo di spermatozoi c'è
letteralmente una possibilità su 500
milioni di nascere che comunque è
incredibile Se ci
pensate
Ecco oggi ragazzi Vi insegnerò Come
tenere un bambino io che me ne
intendo vedi che lui lo sa Eh siccome
durante la giornata molto semplice
intercorrere in problematiche
pannoli dovremmo essere in grado di
mettere mano a questi problemi quindi
adoperiamoci collaboriamo
[Musica]
Ok salviettine rigorosamente per bambini
deciso
vai
è difficile ok È complicato per cortesia
Allora questa Aspetta
[Musica]
eh
collaborazione Ecco
qua Se invece dobbiamo affrontare tratte
in macchina è opportuno utilizzare il
seggiolino il seggiolino va rivolto col
bambino verso il sedile però in questo
momento per questioni di comodità lo
tengo verso di me che almeno riesco ad
allacciarlo è vero Scusate corretto
giusto dopodiché si inserisce la cintura
di sicurezza
nella
[Musica]
Ma perché invece non ci facciamo una
bellissima passeggiata perché ci
permette di rendere il bambino molto più
parte di questo pianeta parte del mondo
mondo che vi invito a preservare e sennò
sarà un futuro difficile per tutti loro
e noi non lo vogliamo
vero per dare da mangiare un bebè c'è
una cosa importante da fare Bisogna
dargli il latte in polvere il tutto con
una mano perché con l'altra devo tenere
il fagotto quindi
svitiamo il
biberon inseriamo all'interno del
biberon è 120
120 Dopodiché la
scaldiamo nel mentre ragazzi quattro
cucchiaini di latte in polvere il
cucchiaino lo troviamo all'interno un
po' come quelli che fanno
[Musica]
bodybuilding Dopodiché prendete il
montatore video e gli fate inserire
l'acqua della pentola nella
Biber
Dopodiché Dopodiché proviamo il latte e
lo versiamo sul posto sentiamo se la
temperatura è
[Musica]
corretta e glielo diamo
all'info
qua Dopodiché ragazzi dopo una sana
pompata mettiamo il piccolino nella
culla E adesso per conciliare il
sonno le
fiabe
Z scritto
da Michael
Gay e la mamma
disse
Lezzo scocci ha funzionato il bimbo già
dorme e quindi ragazzi anche il video di
oggi è concluso Spero che il video vi
sia piaciuto comunque Ricordatevi sempre
[Musica]
che
F